hey Luke here with the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and I'm going to show
you how to teach a little boy how to bat
okay and I'm going to teach you how to
do it like a boss here okay so all of us
know about t-ball that's nothing fancy I
take my surf fishing rod holder my sand
Spike pound it in the lawn works great
as a little t-ball post right nice and
easy just a piece of PVC pipe is all it
is you can see it works good but there's
a big problem one you end up fetching
the ball all day long which wears you
out faster than the kid and two they get
your
fingers so I got a better
idea all right so I've got a nasty old
baseball that we found in the woods it's
all like beat up and uh I put a sheet
metal screw in it tied my mono straight
to the
screw and uh that's all you need there
you go man
okay all
right all right
Tommy here let me see the pipe yeah we
don't need that pipe anymore okay
[Music]
okay it right way good hit good hit
buddy it's
working
okay focus on
it and get
it it went in
the B all right
buddy woo good hit good
hitan Nathan go get Tommy's giving you
the bat okay now Nathan come here stand
up here okay there you go
swing
woooo
woo
watch
out I'm going try hit it that
[Music]
way it not
make tacked by the
ball Daddy I just got tacked by the ball
you got attacked by the ball yeah oh you
got you got to stand over watch out
[Music]
naan
I there you
go let me do it again
woo I just stand back little far far
away hey Daddy okay let's see what
happens if Daddy hits this sucker dad
woo strip some
drag
nice nice That's a good
hit now what you do is catch the ball
with your hand catch it with your hand
so it stops spinning around there you go
and put it back so it's calm and reset
it now look at that it's still you get
it okay wait focus on it focus
focus woo good
hit all right good let me Focus again
focus focus
focus I just
focus
wo all right so this is uh a $30 rod and
reel set from
Shakespeare and I don't know much about
sports equipment but my guess is that's
cheaper than buying some sort of te-
ball
Satin
what are you trying to hit people with
hammers Tommy are you having fun yeah do
you like this do you like using you like
hitting with your bat yeah that's kind
awesome baby to
hit the B again all right go hit it
woo yay
yay
bunk under the car cry
Tommy are you under the car crying cuz
Nathan's using your
baseball cuz they want turn you want a
turn why don't you come out here and say
please instead of throw in a temper
tantrum
woo good
hit is he going under the car
now does whatever Tommy
does Nathan are you going out of the car
too
come focus focus focus focus
focus
woo that was a good hit I made a home
run I made the Home Run
yay well any rate I hope you like this
video if you click subscribe and click
the little bell button and you'll get
notified we put out multiple videos
every week thanks for
watching